- Now you have members
of the security state or
former members like Petraeus,
like Panetta, like Kinzinger,
saying that if there
is a nuclear use by
Russia in Ukraine,
that we must get directly
involved in this war.
We must now bomb every Russian
military asset in Ukraine,
sink every ship that Russia
has in the Black Sea.
This is what very respected
people in the beltway
are calling for.
So we could, this
could tip over into
a hot war in which we
are a full belligerent
at any minute.
(smooth synth intro music)
I'm Dave Rubin, and
joining me today is
the founder of Craft Ventures
and one of the co-hosts
of the "All-In" podcast,
David Sachs, welcome back
to "The Rubin Report."
- Great to be with you
Dave, good to see you.
- David, when I contacted
you a couple weeks ago
to come back on,
it was because you were
getting all sorts of people
very angry at you over
this Ukraine-Russia thing.
And it's bizarre, at least from
where I sit, because to me,
you've been one of
kind of the most sober,
"Hey, let's not rush into war.
What are we doing here?
Is this costing us money?"
and all sorts of stuff.
That's the voice
that you have been,
but I didn't even know
you really cared about
international relations to
this extent before that.
So maybe for people
that don't know you
or why we're even having
this conversation,
maybe we should start there.
Why did you get involved
in this whole conversation?
- Well, I can't imagine an issue
that is more
important to all of us
than whether we get
in World War III,
and it was Biden himself,
it was Biden himself who
said just the other day
that the United States
was at the risk of
getting into what he
called Armageddon.
He said that we faced
the most serious risk of
getting into a nuclear war
since the Cuban Missile Crisis.
And the one time you
can really believe Biden
is when he's off
prompter, right?
He's saying things
spontaneously off the cuff.
So I actually believe that
this is what he thinks
and these are the conversations
that are happening
inside the White House.
And so I think we all should
be very concerned about
where this war is leading us.
In terms of my interest, I mean,
the foreign policy has been an
interest of mine for a while,
but when I saw what was
happening on this issue
and where it was leading,
and specifically we're in an
escalatory spiral with Russia,
which is, you know,
another nuclear power,
it's the country in the world
that has the most
nuclear weapons.
It's really the only
country in the world
that can truly threaten
our own security
because of the sheer number
of ICBMs that they have.
This is the only Achilles
heel that we really have.
Our military is so vastly more
powerful than anybody else.
No one can really touch us
except for this
one issue of ICBMs.
So they do pose a
real threat to us.
So we need to be
very concerned about
where this escalatory
spiral is headed.
And look, my interest is
really just coming at it
from the point of view of
being a concerned American.
And I do this podcast called
"The All-In Pod" every week
where we talk about this issue
and for expressing
any concerns about
where this war is headed,
you're instantly denounced as
some sort of Putin apologist
or agent of the Kremlin
or something like that.
And just to be completely clear,
I have no financial
dealings with Russia
or anyone from Russia.
I invest in American startups.
So, you know, I have no
interest in this other than
coming out from the point of
view of a concerned American.
- And for complete
transparency's sake,
you also were an
investor in Locals
and obviously then we merged
with Rumble and All Goods.
- A very worthy startup.
But yes, these are the types
of, this is what I do is
I invest in startups,
in American companies.
- And David, I can
give you my word
I'm not a Russian operative,
so you're clear on my end.
Okay, so look, I actually have
not covered Russia-Ukraine
a ton on the show because
my general feeling is
there's so much going on
in the United States right now
domestically that is wrong.
I've been just keeping my eye
on that a little bit more,
but my general
thoughts have been
you've got two sovereign
countries here.
You can't invade a sovereign
country, but at the same time,
once he does it and the
guy with the big guns,
with the nukes, if you
don't give him an off ramp,
we could really be
in a lot of trouble.
And I think that's where you've
been going with all of this.
Are you shocked the way
people have pushed back on,
"Hey, let's not go
to World War III?"
In your Newsweek
piece, you talked about
this confluence of now the
wokesters and the neocons
who you'd think have nothing
in common, how they're really
the driving force of
this whole thing now.
- Right, well, let's
take an example.
So Elon Musk proposed on Twitter
a simple straw man
for a peace deal.
It was a very, I think, a
pretty reasonable framework.
It basically said that,
listen, we will do elections
in these disputed territories
in eastern Ukraine,
not sham elections,
but elections under
the supervision of,
say, the United
Nations peacekeepers
and election monitors.
We recognize that Crimea
is a fait accompli,
Russia annexed it 2014,
that ship has sailed.
And you know, we
recognize that Ukraine
will not become part of
NATO, which Russia feels is
very threatening to
their own security,
but we can sell them weapons
and give them
security guarantees.
That was roughly the proposal,
by the way, those rough
contours of a peace deal
have been suggested by many
experts for over a year
to resolve this crisis.
But in any event,
my point is this,
that he was denounced by no
less than Zelenskyy himself
who took to Twitter
to basically say that
the mere suggestion
of a peace deal
was acting in
pro-Russian interests.
So this is the point in the
debate that we've reached
is that if you raise
even the idea of
trying to find a diplomatic
solution to this war,
or if you bring up
any of the pre-history
to what happened
before February 24th,
if you point out that
the West's desire for
NATO expansion right up
to Russia's front porch
might have played a role
in creating this conflict.
If you bring up any idea that
that's not on board with,
I would say maximalist
Ukrainian demands
to take back every
square inch of territory
that they consider to be theirs,
then you are now pro-Russian
and a Kremlin agent.
- Where do you think, or
what do you think that
that says about Zelenskyy?
That he obviously
is outgunned here,
he's getting a crazy
amount of money
and all sorts of
weapons and technology
and everything else
from all over the world,
but as you say,
he's maximalist on
"get the hell outta
here, guy with nukes."
And that doesn't seem normally
how the symmetry of something
like this would play out.
As Kamala Harris said,
Russia big Ukraine small.
- Well, so I think at the
beginning of the wars,
Zelenskyy himself was
floating peace deals
that were not dissimilar
from what Elon suggested.
He said that he was open to
taking the issue of NATO
expansion off the table.
And then unfortunately
Boris Johnson
went to Ukraine in April
and killed that peace deal.
And now since then,
there have been so many
losses on both sides,
but especially the Ukrainians
have suffered so much
that there's no longer any
appetite for a peace deal.
I understand that this
is what happens in war
is that people experience so
much loss, so much devastation
that they get more dug
in on their position,
and Zelenskyy is
following a position of
Ukrainian nationalism, that
is what his country supports.
Now, I think the
mistake would be for us,
even though I think
we sympathize with
their Ukrainian nationalism,
their desire for sovereignty,
I think that we have to consider
what's in America's
own interest.
Zelenskyy is representing
what's in his own
country's interest,
what's in Ukraine's interest.
But we need to think about
what's in the United
States' interest.
And the fact of the matter is
we are getting increasingly
drawn in to this conflict
in a deeper and deeper
way to the point where
now we actually might face
the risk of a nuclear war.
And I think it's about time that
somebody on the American
side started saying,
"Listen, we understand the
Ukrainian position on this.
We sympathize with you, we're
willing to give you aid,
but what are our limits?
What is in the
American interest?"
And those are the questions
we'd be asking right now.
- Do you think
this administration
has the American
interest at heart?
- Well, at the
beginning of the war,
Biden said some sensible things.
So for example, what he said
is that the U.S. would not
get directly involved in a
shooting war with Russia.
He understood and said that
could cause World War III,
we're not messing
around with that.
And so, for example, he vetoed
the idea of a no fly zone,
which hardliners, you know,
the Twitter mob wanted.
And various
congressional elites,
Lindsey Graham and
so forth wanted.
Yeah, that was a smart decision.
Also, when Lester Holt asked him
in a press interview at the
very beginning of the war,
he said, "Mr. President,
what if there's
Americans trapped
behind enemy lines,
would you send in our
troops to go get them?"
And Biden said no,
even in that case
we will not get directly
involved in this war.
He didn't let the
press goad him into
a direct American involvement.
But the problem is that
since then we've been
on a slippery slope
and we've begotten
more and more involved.
So for example, you've now had
administration officials
brag to publications
like the New York Times
and the Washington Post
about killing Russian generals,
providing the intelligence
that paints the
target on their back,
about providing the
intelligence, the
artillery spotting
to sink the Moskva, which
is the Russian flagship.
You've had
administration officials
bragging about the
role they played in
this recent Ukrainian
counter offense.
Basically, the Ukrainians
presented plans
to the American generals.
The American said these
plans aren't good enough.
They hand corrected them,
sent them back to Ukraine.
And they're bragging about
this in the New York Times.
We also keep appropriating
them more and more money,
more and more weapons and more
and more advanced weapons.
And so we are getting
more and more involved.
There also was a New York
Times report about how America
now has commandos, we have
boots on the ground in Ukraine,
maybe not pulling the triggers
or pushing the buttons on
the Himars and so forth,
but they're on the ground
directing the flow
of weaponry and aid.
And so they are in harm's
way and they could get killed
thereby drawing us
in even further.
So we are very involved
in this war, Dave,
and we are getting more
involved by the day.
- It's interesting 'cause
we call it "this war,"
we don't really say "our war,"
but do you think we're,
in essence, do you think,
I know we haven't declared war
and this hasn't gone to Congress
and any of that kind of stuff,
but do you feel like we
actually are at war right now?
What do you think the average
Americans should feel like?
I mean we're
funding it seemingly
endlessly, as you said,
weapons and and training
and a whole bunch more.
I mean, do you
think, in essence,
we are at war, whether
it's declared or not?
- We are basically
at the point now
where we are effectively a
co-belligerent in this war
in the sense that,
like you said,
we're providing the weapons,
we're training the Ukrainians
on how to use those weapons,
including on American soil.
We are providing
the intelligence,
we're providing
the battle plans,
we are doing everything
except for pulling the triggers
and taking the bullets.
Which, and I don't
wanna minimize that
because the Ukrainians are
suffering a lot of losses,
but we are this close
to basically being
directly involved.
And now you have members
of the security state or
former members like Petraeus,
like Pinetta, like Kinzinger
saying that if there
is a nuclear use by
Russia in Ukraine,
that we must get directly
involved in this war.
We must now bomb every Russian
military asset in Ukraine,
sink every ship that Russia
has in the Black Sea.
This is what very respected
people in the beltway
are calling for.
So this could tip
over into a hot war
in which we are a full
belligerent at any minute.
And you know, I think that
we need to be thinking about
why would we do that.
The fact of the matter is
that prior to this year,
no American president in the
history of the United States
ever declared Ukraine
or any part of Ukraine
to be a vital interest
the United States.
We do not have a vital
national interest in
who rules the Donbas or Crimea.
We simply don't.
That, by the way,
and Biden realized this at
the beginning of the war,
this is why he said we will
not get directly involved.
It's 'cause he realized that
America did not have a
vital national interest.
But we, through
this slippery slope,
are getting closer and closer
to getting into a
war with Russia,
which could be a nuclear war,
even though we have no
vital interests at stake.
- So if we don't have
a vital interest there,
putting aside, okay, a
certain amount of people
just like war or the idea of war
or the profiteering
off war, you know,
a lot of people are saying
this is just basically
the biggest money laundering
scheme in history,
that Afghanistan wrapped up,
and that somehow a ton of
money laundering happened,
and now it's just been
shifted to Ukraine.
Do you think there's
validity to that?
- Yeah, I mean,
the argument was,
this was, I think, put
in a clever way that
the idea was that you had
Afghanistan on one end
and on the other hand was
the American, well, sorry,
you had the American
taxpayer on one end,
on the other end was basically
the military industrial complex.
And in between was
this laundry machine
that washed all the
money and kept it going.
We had that for 20
years in Afghanistan.
It was an operation that cost us
literally trillions of dollars.
The total bill for all of
our misbegotten adventures
in the Middle East,
these forever wars, is
roughly $8 trillion.
And it was only six months after
the Afghan war
finally was ended.
After 20 years of us
not even knowing what
we're doing there anymore,
I guess we're on some crazy
nation-building project,
but after 20 years of that, we
only went six months without
there being a new war
basically declared.
That is a full
employment program
for the military
industrial complex.
Now look, I think the
motivations for this are
more complicated than just that.
I think there's a strong
ideological component,
but there's no question that
if you peel back the layers of
who funds these think tanks
that are always
clamoring for war,
that are funding all these
blue checks on Twitter
who basically are clamoring
for more and more involvement.
There's a lot of
defense contractors
who basically are footing the
bills for these think tanks.
And it's high time,
in my opinion,
that these think
tanks and so forth
and these columnists who
are always bringing for war
disclose who there
are donors are.
They're constantly
accusing people
on the side who want
a diplomatic solution
of somehow being
pro-Russian sympathizers.
I've already declared I
have no Russian investors,
I have no Russian interest.
Can they declare the same thing
about Ukrainian oligarchs?
And by the way, we know
what was Hunter Biden doing
receiving millions of dollars
from Ukrainian oligarchs
just shortly before
this war started.
So there are connections here
that I think deserve
to be explored.
- Right, and then just
watching the reaction to
your Newsweek piece, which
I thought was excellent,
I'm gonna quote a couple
lines of it in a moment.
And then watching when Elon
put the Twitter poll up,
which we did cover,
and all of these people
who you'd think would have
respect for Elon Musk at least,
maybe they don't care
about his politics,
but like, all right,
he's an interesting guy.
Maybe we need to like mix
this thing up a little bit,
just watching
people go after him-
- Well, more than that, Dave.
- Right, now they're saying,
who was it, was it
Lindsey Graham that said
maybe we should look into some
of his government contracts
or something after that, right?
- Yeah, exactly.
And David Fromm said that we
should nationalize Starlink.
So, but yeah, both
of 'em said that.
So, but here's the
amazing thing is
Elon Musk is the reason why,
a big part of the reason why
Ukraine is still in this war.
Without Starlink,
which is Elon's satellite
communication system,
which allows Ukrainians to get
internet access in the field
in the most remote
parts of Ukraine,
the Ukrainian military effort
would not have communications.
And this is what is basically
powering their tablets
and their targeting
systems and their drones
is that they have internet
access through Starlink.
Elon said that SpaceX, his
company, has borne this,
they donated Starlink
to the Ukrainian cause
at a out of pocket cost
to them of $80 million.
It's about $20 million a month.
And when Elon finally said,
listen, we're not
seeking payment
for the donation we
made in the past,
but moving forward,
we can't afford
as an unprofitable company
to keep funding this.
You know, we'd like to get
paid like maybe, you know,
Lockheed Martin or Raytheon,
these defense contractors
are making massive
amounts of money
selling Javelins or Himars.
Maybe we'd like to
get paid like that.
There was this
hysterical reaction
by people like Lindsay Graham,
by people like David Fromm
who somehow feel entitled to
conscript a private
American company
into funding this war forever.
- And by the way, it's worth
noting that David Fromm
was George W.
Bush's speechwriter
who wrote the "axis
of evil" speech
that got us into the Iraq War.
You'd think that these
people would have
a little bit of shame or
a little bit of humility,
but they just keep coming back.
I guess that's what your
point is, that there's this,
they recycle these same people
basically who get
everything wrong.
- Yeah, I think it's a
really important point that
the exact same people
who are supporting
greater and greater involvement
in this war by America,
who say that any diplomatic
solution would be appeasement
and would be pro-Putin,
they are the exact same
people who lied us into Iraq,
who lied us into, literally,
with the false claims
of WMD programs
and the false claims
that Saddam Hussein was
somehow linked up and in
cahoots with Al-Qaeda.
So they made that up.
They also made up that
somehow we needed to be in
Afghanistan for 20 years.
They lied us into Syria,
they lied us into Libya.
Their foreign policy
has been a disaster
for the last 20 years.
These are not people who
should be trusted as experts,
and yet they claim,
and I'm in a Twitter
spat right now
with a guy named Tom Nichols,
they're all writers at
The Atlantic, by the way.
(Dave chuckling)
The Atlantic is like the most
pro-war magazine, and yet-
- Oh, you'll get
Lincoln Project next.
It starts with The Atlantic-
- Oh yeah, Stuart Stevens is
hitting me too, by the way,
Stuart Stevens, this guy is
a political hitman for hire
who has literally worked
for foreign autocrats, okay?
So, and members of
the Lincoln Project
have actually taken
Russian money in the past
to lobby on behalf of Russia.
And these political hit men
are coming after me on Twitter
for advocating peace.
Any event, none of these
people should be trusted.
They are not experts.
They are, I guess you'd
call them failed experts.
And they claim that they
are in possession of
special knowledge,
special abilities.
They have special credentials
that should make all
of us defer to them.
Well, look in my business,
which is investing,
what do you look at?
You look at a track record.
These people have
a track record of
being nothing but
wrong for 20 years,
and we need to stop
listening to them
and taking everything
they say at face value.
- Also, have any
of them, you know,
I've seen some of the Twitter
spats that you've got into,
and most, usually, they're
honestly just insulting you.
They're not really coming
back with the ideas,
which, surprise surprise,
that's what Twitter
is at this point.
But has anyone come
back to you and said,
"Well, actually, this is
what the win looks like."
Like actually, if we
just keep funding him
and we just keep giving him
weapons and just enough money,
that actually Russia will fold.
A few weeks ago, remember there
were like two or three days
where people were like,
"Russia is losing."
And I was like, "Well, again,
he still has the nukes,"
but now nobody's saying
Russia is losing anymore.
- Right, so you're
right in terms of
the responses that
I get on Twitter
it's precious few arguments.
It's really just one ad
hominem attack after another.
We've seen this before in
domestic politics, right?
It's woke cancellation
tactics that
they don't respond to you
by citing rational
arguments and logic.
They try to accuse
you of something.
They're not trying to
participate in the debate.
They're trying to
shut down the debate.
And so we see on
this Ukraine war is
a marriage of this sort of
woke mob with these neocons,
these sort of hawkish neocons
who've been wrong about
everything in foreign policy
for the last 20 years.
And this marriage
has come together.
And the reason why it's
so dangerous is because
it's shaping our
discourse in a way
to basically
preclude and exclude
any discussion of a
diplomatic settlement.
And if you basically
de-legitimize anybody
who is basically
speaking up for peace
as somehow being pro-Russian,
you take those options off
the table, so what is left?
All that's left is
greater escalation,
more dangerous escalation
with a logical result that
we could eventually find
ourselves in a war with Russia.
- I'm gonna either do you
a major favor right now,
or you're gonna be pissed at me,
but if I can get
Kinzinger or Fromm
or one of these
guys to debate you,
I mean, my feelings
on this are clear,
so I'm guessing that
they won't do it,
but if I can get 'em to do it,
would you be down to do it?
Just to be clear?
- Yeah, sure, I mean, yes.
I mean I'm already
debating them on Twitter.
They don't really
have an answer.
I mean, you know, anyway,
look, I read all their tweets
so I understand where
they're coming from.
Basically, it's just one
straw man and accusation
after another.
They really are
not interested in
finding a diplomatic
solution here.
And here's why this
is so dangerous
is that if you listen
to what they're saying,
they believe that the only
acceptable outcome to this war
is total Ukrainian victory,
which they are letting
Ukrainian nationalists
determine what that means.
And what the Ukrainians
say is that they want back
every square inch of
Ukraine going back to 2014.
So that includes Crimea.
Crimea is where the rubber
meets the road on this.
Because I think
that most, I'd say,
or many foreign policy experts
who've really looked at this,
understand that Putin and Russia
will never let Crimea go back.
They will be willing to
use battlefield nukes
to prevent the total loss,
their total defeat in this war,
and to prevent Crimea
from being overrun
and retaken by Ukraine.
Why is that?
Because Russia has
a giant naval base
at Sevastopol in Crimea
which is home to
the Black Sea fleet.
If they lose Crimea, they
presumably lose Sevastopol,
they lose the Black Sea fleet.
That is a vital
interest to them.
This would be like
if the United States were to
lose Hawaii and Pearl Harbor.
Putin will never give that up.
He will be willing
to use battlefield
nukes to prevent that.
Now, by the way,
that doesn't mean
he won't be willing to
use them prior to that,
but I think at the very
least, I think that
he would be willing to use them,
or so I believe and so
many people believe.
So this idea that we can just
support Ukrainian
maximalist demands
until they overrun Crimea or
this turns into a nuclear war,
at some point we're gonna have
to sit the Ukrainians down,
sit Zelenskyy down and say,
"Sorry, we've supported you to
this point, whatever this is.
But you cannot have Crimea back.
We are not willing to let
this conflict go nuclear."
- Did you happen to
catch any of Rand Paul
when he was asking the Congress
or he was asking the Senate,
basically, the House, you know,
"Hey guys, we're giving
them all this money.
Could we just get some
receipts on this stuff?"
And basically everyone
just made fun of him.
I mean, all the
guy was saying was,
"Hey, if we're gonna give
him 20 billion a pop,
could we just a couple
receipts, would that be okay?"
And we just simply
don't do it, do we?
- What Rand Paul asked
for was an accountant.
Yeah, literally an accountant.
It's called a Special
Inspector General.
- Yeah.
- But it's a fancy
name for an accountant.
He said, "Listen,
we're appropriating
over $40 billion in this bill,"
by the way, the tab now is
up to something like 80,
"we need to know where
this money goes,"
because, by the
way, in Afghanistan,
we didn't know how
much money was wasted
until they appointed a
special inspector general
named John F. Sopko,
and he has written report
after report of the malfeasance
and what went wrong in Ukraine
and how this money
was squandered.
By the way, that guy
deserves a medal of honor
from the next president
because what he's
turned up is shocking.
And to now go into a new war,
appropriating tens of
billions of dollars
more than we appropriate
for our own border security
and not have so much
as an accountant
keeping track of where
the money's going.
And by the way, Ukraine is
one of the most corrupt
countries in the world.
Russian and Ukraine are
basically like one space apart
in the listings of
national corruption.
And by the way, I mean, listen,
I know Zelenskyy is a
hero to a lot of people,
but the Panama
Papers revealed that
he had hundreds of
millions of dollars
squirreled away offshore
with Ukrainian oligarchs
who have been involved in
various corruption scandals.
So listen, I mean the corruption
in that country is massive.
For us to be appropriating
billions of dollars
without an accountant
is shocking.
And I just don't understand
how Congress can do that.
- What do you make of
the sort of swarm effect,
like right when
this thing happened,
remember those three
days where immediately,
okay, everybody has to
put the Ukraine flag
on their Twitter
and Facebook avatar
and then EA sports takes
the Russian national team
off PlayStation
hockey, literally,
and we're moving
vodka out of stores
and all of this insanity.
What do you make of that
collective sort of brain dump
that everyone does when
these things happen
and they turn out to
actually do nothing?
Or if anything, you're harming
some guy who lives in Brooklyn
who's a vodka importer.
You're not harming
Vladimir Putin.
- Listen, I think it was an
emotional knee jerk reaction
to the invasion.
I mean, look, the
fact of the matter is
the media has not been
covering what's been going on
in Ukraine prior to February 24.
So the American people
tuned in for the first time
when the invasion happened,
and naturally they
had a reaction of
outrage and revulsion
to what the Russians were doing.
However, did that
knee jerk reaction
result in anything good?
One of the things
you saw is that
American companies all left
Russia and they left literally
billions and billions of
dollars of assets on the table
with the result.
Now, who paid the
price for that?
American pension funds who own
the stocks of these companies
who've lost all of this money?
Billions and billions were lost.
By the way, if Putin had simply
nationalized those assets
and taken them away
from American companies,
we would've been screaming
about theft, of course,
because it would've
been theft, right?
So I think some of the
actions we've taken
in response to the outrage,
and I understand the outrage
and I understand that people
can be genuinely outraged,
but this is a time for
cooler heads to prevail.
And now we're at the point where
the outrage may take us all
the way into nuclear war
if we're not careful.
So it is high time to
move past the outrage
and to start having some
cooler heads prevail here.
- Is there anyone politically
in America that you know
that's in politics, a senator or
I guess it's not the president
that's making some sense
to you on all of this?
'Cause it's funny, I
mean, I'm looking at
my list of people that
are making sense on this
and it's a lot of tech guys
and it's people that are
cultural commentators
and YouTubers,
but it's not really
the political people.
Again, I would exclude Rand
Paul, he's making some sense.
There's probably
a couple others.
- By and large that's true.
So, the people who I listen to,
again, I look at track
record, I always try to ask,
well, who predicted
this situation?
Who understood that we were
about to get into this?
Who recommended paths for
avoiding this conflict?
And if you go back and look,
there were many people,
just not the ones that
Washington pays attention to,
back in the 1990s,
you had George Kent,
who was the architect of our
Cold War containment policy,
warn that if we
brought NATO expansion
all the way up to
Russia's border,
it would result in
a tragic mistake.
You had basically back in 2014,
after you had this
sort of Crimea crisis,
you had the international
relations scholar John Mirshimer
explain that we were on a
course that was headed for war.
I really urge everybody to
watch his lecture from 2014
on YouTube, it's gone viral,
it has 28 million views.
- [David] Yeah, we'll
link to it down below.
- To get a deeper
understanding of this conflict,
listen to people
like Jeffrey Sachs,
who's the international
development economist,
very liberal guy.
I mean, this is
somebody who I think
had a lot of relationships
in the Obama White House
who basically will affirm that
this conflict began
before February 24th.
It really began years ago
with America trying to
bring NATO right up to
Russia's front porch.
Remember in the Cuban missile
crisis, what provoked that?
Why was America willing
to use nuclear weapons?
Because Russia had
entered into an alliance,
a military alliance with Cuba
and was trying to move
missiles right onto our border.
We reacted strongly to that.
We were willing to get into
a nuclear war over that
because we realized
the military threat.
But we refused to recognize
that the Russians could
basically perceive
American missiles and bases
directly on their most
vulnerable border,
which is Ukraine,
as a similar kind of threat.
And it's been our unwillingness
to take the NATO expansion
issue off the table,
which we could have
done earlier this year,
we could have done
it in December,
it in January,
the administration
refused to do it,
if we had done that,
I do not believe
there'd be a war today.
- Do you think the march
for the NATO expansion,
for Ukraine to get in
NATO is gonna continue?
- Yes, I mean, so here's
the tell on this is that
the very same people who say
this war has nothing to
do with NATO expansion,
people like McFall
and various others,
in the next breath they will say
we cannot take NATO
expansion off the table,
that is non-negotiable.
Well, hold on a second.
If this war has nothing
to do with NATO expansion,
why can't you take
it off the table?
This war has everything
to do with NATO expansion.
This is a crusade that
goes back many years, okay?
Our state department
has been engaged on
this long term
project to basically
bring NATO right up
to Russia's borders.
And that has provoked a very
strong response from Russia.
By the way, I'm not
justifying the invasion.
It was wrong, it was criminal.
But the fact of
the matter is that
we could have diffused this
crisis before the war began
if we were willing
to use diplomacy.
And I believe that even today
we could try to
engage in diplomacy,
take NATO expansion
off the table,
recognize that Crimea
is a fait accompli,
and then support some sort
of negotiated settlement
over the Donbas region.
If we were just to agree
to those three things,
which seem very sensible,
America has no vital interest,
and any of those three
things that would supersede
or that would necessitate us
to get into a war with Russia,
if we were just to
do those things,
I believe there's a good
chance we could end this war.
- And in some ways, is
it almost a moot point
whether they were to
get in NATO or not?
Because if we're in an endless
war that we're funding,
whether they're in it or
not, we're kind of in it.
That's the point, right?
- Well, a couple of things.
So first of all,
obviously Ukraine is
more than capable of
defending themselves
if we sell them weapons
without them being in NATO.
So if this war has
proven anything,
it's that Ukraine doesn't
need to be in NATO.
Furthermore, however,
we need to think about
is it really in
America's interest
for Ukraine to be in NATO?
Because if Ukraine were in NATO,
they would have an article
five guarantee, which means
the next time that they
get in a war with Russia,
and they will, 'cause
that feud's been going on
for hundreds of years,
we will be instantly obligated
to get in a war with Russia.
This is why historically we
have not brought them into NATO.
This is why there
was reluctance.
We stated our intention
to do so back in 2008
and we were slowly
building towards it.
But there was
always concern that
if we were actually to
bring Ukraine into NATO,
it would obligate us to
get into a war with Russia.
And by the way, if you
like the feeling of
living with a nuclear threat,
remember when I was a kid,
we lived under this threat
of nuclear annihilation.
We had movies like "The
Day After" that showed
what it was like if we
got in a nuclear war.
I remember that, as a kid,
it was not a good feeling
to grow up living under the
shadow of nuclear annihilation.
We solved that problem.
We won the Cold War in
1991, and now it is back.
It is back.
We have been living this year
under the shadow
of a nuclear war.
So listen, if you like that
feeling, then by all means
bring Ukraine into NATO
as soon as possible
because we will
be forever living
under the threat of
nuclear annihilation
because again, article
five will trigger us
to get into a nuclear
war with Russia.
So it is a foolish idea, it
was always a foolish idea.
It is not in American interest
to bring Ukraine into NATO
and yet these crusaders
in the state department
have made it their mission.
And we need to take
that issue off the table
as soon as possible.
- Sachs, that is a primo close.
However, I am gonna ask
you one other thing,
but I do wanna just give a shout
out to your Newsweek piece,
which was called "The
Neocons and the Woke Left
are Joining Hands and Leading
Us to Woke War Three."
We'll also link to that down
below. Now I just wanna ask you
something sort of personal
on all of this, which is that
you're obviously doing all
right, you don't need to be
taking the slings and
arrows for this thing,
yet you're doing it.
And it's interesting to
me, as I said before,
that suddenly I'm finding
the people that I'm
interested in politically
are tech people and
business people.
They're not the politics people.
But it can't be all
fun doing this for you,
even though I know you care
about it and all that stuff.
But yeah, you know, you're
putting your neck out there,
you have businesses
and all those things.
- Dave, if I saw more people
who are part of the foreign
policy establishment
speaking out and being
just a little bit brave,
willing to basically be
called a pro-Russian puppet
to advocate for
diplomacy and peace,
it wouldn't be on
people like me to do it.
But the fact of the matter is,
I don't care what
these people say.
I have, I've told you before,
I've got no business interest.
I'm not part of this foreign
policy establishment.
I'm not beholden to their
sort of insider club.
And you know what, if we
get in a war with Russia,
then that's gonna interrupt
the operations of
my venture fund.
Let's just say that, okay?
We're gonna have much more
important things to worry about
then my next star investment.
So it's my obligation as an
American citizen to speak out.
I believe that is why
Elon Musk spoke out.
He is a very informed
person, by the way.
He knows people
all over the world.
He is very concerned about
this, just read his tweets.
He's taking a lot of flack too.
Bill Ackman recently spoke out,
who, by the way, we've been
debating each other on Twitter
for a while about this.
And he recently spoke out.
So you're seeing more and
more people speak out.
Their only interest here is that
they are concerned about
America and they do not see
people in the foreign policy
establishment and politicians
speaking out the
way they should be.
And that includes
the Republican party,
who frankly has completely
dropped the ball on this issue.
- David, I always tell people
if we were just a
little bit braver,
things would be a lot better.
So, I love that finish.
Good talking to you, my friend.
- Great to see you, thanks Dave.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlists all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.